معارك تستعر في المنطقه الشرقيه والجنوبيه
من اوكرانيا على حد سواء كانت القوات
الروسيه تتقدم في عده محاور فيزا باروجي
واعلن عن هدوء او يعني طرح هدوء في
المعارك في منطقه زبروجي من ناحيه روسيا
لكن الجانب الاوكراني استمر بقصف عده مدن
تابعه للجانب الروسي لكن يعني فوجئنا
باعلان انفجار او فيديوهات ظهرت الانفجار
كبير قالت السلطات هناك في زبروج التابعه
لروسيا بان هذا الانفجار يعني اسفر عن
قتيل ضابط شرطه وانه ان سببه الاساس هو
عمل ارهابي ان هناك مازال من يتعامل مع
الجانب الاوكراني من اجل يعني خلق البلابل
والمشاكل داخل المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا لكن المحاور الاخرى احمد اذا سمحت
لي بالفعل تشهد استعارا بالم الضاريه خاصه
التي اعلن
نائب او مستشار القائم باعمال مقاطعه
دانيسكا التابعه لروسيا بانه بان الجيش
الروسي قاب قوسين او ادنى من اكمال
الدائره السيطره على شكل دائره حول باقمت
واذا اكملت السيطره على باقمه بشكل دائره
فهذا يعني قطع الامدادات حتى الصفر اي ان
الجيش الاوكراني سيكون محاصر وستنفذ ذخيره
لكن حتى الان ما دام الحديث عن عدم
الاكمال الكامل اذا هناك امدادات ما زالت
تصل للقوات الاوكرانيه داخل باخمت وما
زالت تقاتل حرب شوارع او قتال شوارع في
الناحيه الجنوبيه والناحيه الشرقيه من
المدينه قوات فاجنر تقاتل هناك وتحاول
اختراق المدينه من منطقه ايفانوفكا في
الناحيه الجنوبيه ومن مراكز يعني
كامل اللحوم ومسالخ اللحوم في المنطقه
الشرقيه المنطقه الشرقيه يوم امس شاهدت
معارك عنيفه بالفعل وحاولت القوات الروسيه
التقدم في هذا المحور كما ان المحور
الشمالي من المنطقه نحو
ايضا تقوم قوات فاجنر بمحاوله اختراق
المدينه محاولات كثيره مغطاه بالقصف
المدفعي والصاروخي كما ان هناك حضور كبير
في المنطقه حول مدينه باقمت وفي مقاطعه
دانياس بشكل عام لسلاح الجو المقاتلات
الروسيه باتت بشكل دائم طول النهار يعني
يعني تتجول في سماء هذا بخصوص
هناك ايضا حديث عن اوغلي دار رائد التي
حدثت مصادر مقاربه من روسيا بانها قد
القوات الروسيه قد سيطرت على جزء كبير من
محيط هذه المدينه وقطعه الامدادات ايضا عن
الجيش الاوكراني في الداخل ما الذي تمثله
هذه المنطقه الجيش الروسي
طبعا
في جنوب المقاطعه قال ايضا
كيما كوفسكي نائب القائم باعمال الرئاسه
هنا
بان الجيش الروسي احاط او طوق المدينه
بشكل نصف دائره اي ان هناك نصف الدائره
الثاني متصل بالجانب الاخر الامدادات تصل
للقوات الاوكرانيه الحديث عن
حصون كبيره ومتينه للجيش الاوكراني على
اطراف المدينه
الحديث عن دبابات باعداد كبيره واسلحه
اليات ثقيله موجوده قال ايضا جاجين نائب
نائب رئيس الجمهوريه المعترف بها من روسيا
هنا بان الجيش الروسي حتى الان لم يتمكن
من الدخول الى المدينه هنا